welcome to another dr sadler's honest
review
this is a series in which i review
usually fairly recent books within
philosophy
focused on the practical side of
philosophy how it impacts
our day-to-day life how we make
decisions
how we ought to behave and so of course
that
bleeds over into many other fields like
those of leadership or ethics more
broadly
or self-help or in this case
the area of mindfulness and so the book
that i'm reviewing today
is called mindfulness and the big
questions philosophy for now
and the author is ben irvine
and it was uh published in 2017 with
leaping hair press which is an imprint
of quarto
so it's actually you know quite an
attractive
uh little volume here i'll show you
what it looks like right there and so
uh as always with these i'm going to
talk a little bit about the style
structure
the summary some of the key ideas of the
book
some of the things that i think are good
points about it
some of the things that i find
problematic
and then give you some some final
verdict but i'll say
right off the bat it's i'm going to give
this a mixed review
there are some really good features
about this book
there are some things that i find
lacking
or off base or underdeveloped as
as well in the book and so you know
whether or not you would want to get
your hands on this will probably depend
on
which of those matter the you know more
to you the positive aspects or the
things that i
thought were problematic
i like to begin with the three big s's
a summary of the work which the author
is in fact
providing us with at several different
points a
discussion of the works style and
a sort of overall structure and so let's
actually start with the
last one first because that's fairly
easy to discuss so it's divided into
seven chapters and then there's you know
a very short
further reading sort of recommendations
there's an index
and then there are some acknowledgments
at the very end of it
and the chapters are divided up along
the lines with the exception of the very
first one
along the lines of what we can call the
big questions which
makes good sense because this is called
mindfulness and the big questions
and when we're using that term big
questions in philosophy
we generally mean the sorts of things
that actually provide
chapter headings here and you know sort
of boxes in which we put a whole bunch
of
related topics so the first one is
called hidden in plain sight and it's
kind of an introduction
to the whole point of of the work and
you know making an argument for for why
mindfulness would be a good thing to do
meditation would be a good thing to do
uh tells you a little bit of the story
of the author which we'll talk about in
a bit and then the second chapter is
called
why am i here so a really big question
right
what's the point of me being here
in in this body am i just my body
am i something besides my body you know
why
am i in the particular place that i am
the second chapter do i really know
anything
that might make you think that it's
really just about epistemology but but
actually
you know there's a lot of practical
concerns built into that
and then we have a big heavy hitter mi
free right so the question of freedom
and determinism and what causality
is these are metaphysical questions
is there a higher power bringing in the
question
of god or whatever else we want to
consider does that make any impact in
our life uh
chapter six is what makes a life good so
we're looking at ethics in a very broad
sense there
and then the rather short chapter seven
is called
what does it all mean and and you can
look at that as having to do with the
meaning of life but also
a way of bringing an end to to the
the section and i will say each chapter
has a bunch of different sections to it
some of them are kind of long some of
them are kind of short
and you know they're they're set up
pretty well there's um you know
it begins with a set of questions that
we we should think about and raise
and then there'll be discussions about
issues um
usually at some point in the chapter not
always at the very end but um you know
sometimes
close to the end there will be a
meditation or practical
exercise that one would carry out and so
it's you know kind of a guided
structured way of doing that
and you know then the the stuff that you
would want to look up at the very end of
it all these references that the author
is making
you're going to find you know either in
the index or
in the further reading which i'll talk a
little bit about
later on so let's talk
then about the summary i i mentioned
that the
author gives us a kind of summary so
actually the very back cover uh
reads like this face up to life
existential anxiety
a fear of our very existence is
something we all have to deal with in
our lives
some of us try to escape from this fear
through hiding in the distractions that
modern life offers us
some of us turn to philosophy but alas
philosophers throughout the ages have
rarely offered good advice
on how to face up to life this book
explores how mindfulness
can enhance our understanding of who and
where we are
enabling us to come to terms with our
existence and embrace being here
now so that tells you really you know
he's laying his position out
philosophers have you know rarely
offered good advice on how to face up to
life
we're going to consider that question in
a bit but i have the recipe for you now
and it's you know it's sort of a furrago
or mix
uh brought together you know one if one
wants to be charitable an
integration of some insights from
philosophy
and some insights from psychology and
some things taken from mindfulness
and some things taken from philosophy
coming from the east
now and we're going to talk about you
know the use of that
in in a bit as well and some you know
stories about ordinary life
and and the author's own experiences
some pop culture references
all of these brought together to try to
help people
understand their life and to live a
better life so you could say that it is
a philosophical
work in that the author is taking a sort
of like
right now perspective and saying what
can we make of
the human condition in its many
different
uh points at the present given the tools
and resources
that we we have available right now
and you know he's got a couple other
places where he says some interesting
things
that i i marked so um
here we go uh he after discussing
mindfulness and cognitive behavior
therapy
he says that my small answers to the big
questions
are like a course of cbt that is
cognitive behavior therapy
for people who suffer from existential
anxiety which he thinks is everybody
at least you know we should be right
when we follow the example of most
philosophers when we distract ourselves
from existence
by hiding in life denying answers to the
big questions
we deliberately lose ourselves in
tangled thickets of thought
through my life affirming small answers
i learned to beat a path through the
confusion of life denying philosophy
yet until i discovered mindfulness i was
still tangled up in the big questions
i was turning the small questions over
and over in my mind like a record player
meditation and mindfulness helped to
create an inner space
where whereby i could distance myself
from my chronic philosophizing
and then i really experienced the small
answers not just abstractly but vividly
and directly
and the small answers came alive through
my mindful experience and i'm
now offering this to to you as a
possibility as well so you notice the
same sort of
you know uh stance on what philosophy
has to offer
um here he talks about it being what
he's
offering here being sort of like a
cognitive behavior therapy approach
um so that's you know uh interesting as
well and then there's another
passage a little bit later in the work
here we go it says when you think about
it this entire
book is an exercise in converting
existential anxiety into a rational
analysis of
human existence through this analysis i
hope to convince you that you needn't be
afraid of your existence but within this
broader project
we can also use rational analysis to
challenge some of our specific fears
about uncertainty and i think that's
kind of emblematic for
you know where the book is is going and
where where it's coming from
um what else to say about it in terms of
style you know it's very readable
i i think that he's a good writer
at least in in the sense of how how he
writes you know it's well put together
the book itself is is quite attractive
aesthetically the way that it has been
developed and it's quite nice to look at
right
feels good in the hand uh very well laid
out
what else is should we say so
there's there's two other elements that
i want to bring up so
it is a it is a sort of self-help book
which is based in philosophy
and incorporating um you know some
research and techniques that are
developed in the present
and um it's uh it's engaging in a good
bit of storytelling as well which which
is quite interesting
uh ben ben irvine you know narrates his
own course of thinking these things
through and i think that that's kind of
for at least for me i find that
interesting and valuable
he also coins a lot of uh well not a lot
he coined some
new terms sometimes in ways that can be
helpful you know there's one for example
he calls it remindfulness and opposes it
to mindfulness
he says this state of being tacitly
aware of our freedom
even when we're acting spontaneously
could be called remindfulness
it's an important part of mindfulness
it's how mindfulness echoes in
spontaneous behavior
enabling us to return to our freedom
whenever we hit obstacles
and it's also how we naturally return to
mindfulness even when things are
going well and he talks about an
oscillation between mindfulness and
re-mindfulness okay so that's kind of
interesting
he also talks about world side
you know uh self-side and and
god's side and these are sort of
elements or or perspectives that we're
supposed to be putting together
rather than being substance duelists or
monas or
things like that that's something that
he proposes and he's got his own
terminology for that and
you know authors can do that there's
nothing wrong with it um
and and the way that he brings them up i
don't think that they're going to
lend themselves to misunderstandings so
the neologisms are
probably you know quite appropriate to
the work
that's probably enough about the the
summary the style
and the structure of the work
so what are some some key ideas from the
work that can give you a good sense
about what this book is about and
whether you'd want to get your hands
on a copy uh you know the first thing is
of course
he's exploring what what he's calling
existential anxiety and you know he's
trying to
explain in in a way that i i think
really essentially follows the
existentialists like heidegger
or sartre or people like that how um
you know we all feel it on some level
but we
submerge it or repress it or distract
ourselves from it
and how when you really feel it it can
be debilitating
and so we want to find a way past
that i i would say that is a really key
thing and then you know so we're going
to put together
in history of mindfulness exercises and
the notion of mindfulness or you know
his
earlier philosophers called it
attentiveness you know reflection
all these sorts of things because the
idea of mindfulness has been around for
a very long time
in western philosophy as well as in
in eastern thought
mindfulness cognitive techniques you
know
he's talking in terms of cbt but again
you know very broad
uh spectrum of cognitive techniques
available to us
whether it's in psychology whether it's
in ancient philosophy
or or in other things as well and then
bringing insights in from philosophy and
examining them and thinking
you know one other thing is thinking
about the different range of positions
that
are available that we can pick and
choose from and critically
examining them that that's one thing
that's going on
over and over again in the book um i
think this notion of you know small
answers to the big questions that's kind
of a cool thing to to bring up i mean
the book
is oriented around traditional big
questions
of philosophy not all of them of course
but the ones that the author felt were
the most important and i think it's
actually a you know quite good selection
of of those classic questions and
you know maybe there is something to
this notion that we need
life-size answers rather than just like
super big idealistic
answers to these questions that's that's
kind of an interesting
point as well thinking through these key
philosophical questions
thematizing them that's that's a good
bit of what this
this book is doing obviously it's it's
rather selective
in which things it's going to focus on
but that's you know the prerogative of
any author isn't it
there are a lot of concepts being
brought in from
psychology great example of this
would be you know the notion of learned
helplessness
or that of depersonalization these are
sort of you know classic at this point
in time uh
psychological you know they like the
word constructs and philosophy we say
concepts or ideas or notions or dynamics
and you know many of those have things
to offer us
i think and so you know the book itself
is is an attempt to i think on the part
sort of like descartes meditations right
it's an attempt
on the author's part to show us where
he's been
in his thinking and then to offer to
us the readers the chance to go down
those
same paths ourselves and to you know
think about whether we
we buy into it or or not and
so you know with each chapter we can
look at
different matters that are being brought
up so let's let's just take the example
of
you know the chapter do i really know
anything which begins by talking about
everyone knowing where they were on 9 11
and
uncertainty now notice that he's not
just talking about
you know epistemology in the sense of
like gettier problems or stuff like that
it's you know uncertainty that we're
actually facing in our real lives
and so how you know how do we experience
uncertainty why do we feel uncertain
there's a great line right here perhaps
many of us feel uncertain because we
lack
satisfying social relationships you know
that's that's an interesting idea then
he brings up the truman show
he talks about uh the the issue of
self-absorption and
how this can be existential and then you
know
uh discusses skepticism and
uh rene descartes some eastern
philosophy and the idea of maya
and then he tells us that skepticism and
idealism are manifestations of an
extreme
form of self self-absorption existential
self-absorption it could be called
a symptom of existential anxiety a
symptom of fearing
being here now and you know this is
where
you might say oh that that's that's an
interesting take on
skepticism and idealism uh it's an
interesting opposition that's being made
there i'm not sure
i entirely buy into it but um you know
you could
at least check it out and then he gives
you like a
a discussion here of a kind of exercise
you can do
um be how to persuade somebody to
accept reality and and the first part is
uh you know just realizing that you have
to know something and then
you know revisiting descartes realizing
that yourself
exists and then he says descartes can't
be right because you can't build a self
out of
ethereal mental states the self is
supposed to under underpin whether
that's an
accurate depiction of descartes we'll
talk about later then he brings in david
hume
um talking about how you know in our
practical life we we we're not really
skeptics
and then he goes on and brings in donald
davidson
uh says we we may go plenty wrong but
only on condition in most respects we
are right
um and you know so he's essentially
adopting
cognitive approaches and then finally he
talks about ge more and his famous
here's a hand
you know um and and you know this is um
sort of the way the way the the text
goes so that gives you a good
idea of what you'd be getting into
what do i like about this work or what
do i find
positive or good about this work what
are the things that would recommend it
to you
as a reader i talked about the
aesthetics of it it's a nice looking
work to begin with
and you know as i pointed out earlier
it's very readable
so i think you know this you could put
this in somebody's hands as
like a present and say hey you want to
study some philosophy
um check out what this this guy has to
say
maybe it'll you know provoke some
thoughts on your part
um i i think that there is some also
some nice storytelling done by irvine
about his own
journey and how he arrived at the
conclusions that he's providing you with
in this this work and um i'll say a few
other things as well there there are a
lot of
let's call them useful reflections
reasonings
practices distinctions being made here
i think they're useful largely as
starting points and not as sort of like
you know the last word
on any of these things or you know
genuinely
um you know comprehensive analyses of
these and and
so sometimes even when they're wrong
which does happen in this book
they can be at least useful they can
they can be thought provoking
and there are some interesting
adaptations he calls them meditations in
here
i would call them philosophical
practices they're like you know
what a doe talks about is spiritual
exercises there's a lot of words for
these sorts of things but you know
there's some nice
cognitive you know and affective
uh and practical things that that you do
under the rubric of meditation
in this book and so i think that that's
a valuable component of it right there
some of which he has created himself and
i think that's always cool when an
author is able to
add to the stock of philosophical
practices
that are out there i think there's also
you know there's a lot of critiques of
philosophy in this right so like you
know going back to the back
philosophers throughout the ages have
rarely offered good advice on how to
face up to life
so he's criticizing where
not the philosophers themselves but
maybe like the
you know second third hand versions of
those philosophers
and their viewpoints go wrong so like
you know the wikipedia version
of them maybe you know some of that is
is
it's good to criticize that and it's
good to say
hey um you don't want to just go in that
direction they didn't manage
to uh address this thing over here but
it's it's usually
more like a summary of the philosopher
than the actual philosopher
and his or her works that are doing that
but i think that could be useful for for
some people right again
nice and thought provoking i will say
that there are
a lot of decent
discussions going on in here i'll single
one out about
self-control which which is kind of
interesting
i mean it echoes something that we find
for example in
you know readings of aristotle and
acrasia right
so he tells us that um
uh you know self-control is
is important and sometimes it's okay to
you know
allow yourself some some
indulgence right he says here we go
anyone who's ever studied for an exam
trained for a sporting event or
rehearsed for a concert
will tell you that the best way to keep
up a regime of self-control is to allow
oneself occasional
modest pleasures pleasure in moderation
is a reward for self-control
the reward motivates the effort that
justifies the reward that motivates the
effort
and so on and he says when a
self-control person allows himself to
experience pleasure in moderation
he loosens control of himself without
losing control
i like that that's a nice distinction
nice way of framing it
i think that's an insight that you can
you know take home and put in the bank
so to speak um i think it would be
better if it was brought into
greater you know engagement with like
classic treatments
of that or other contemporary treatments
but but that's good i'm not going to
take away from
what's particularly good in that so
there are you know quite a few things
that i would say
you know would recommend this work um
just to at least to some readers
what do i find problematic about this
book
you know there's there's quite a few
points where
i i have some disagreements or some
criticisms to make and some of them may
be
you know deal breakers for you as a
reader some of them
might be things that you're willing to
overlook
and that's up to you to think about but
it's up to me
to put them in front of you so the first
thing that i'm going to say
is that the engagement with
actual philosophers their texts their
systems their ways of doing things
is often very superficial in this this
work
and in some respects i would say
stereotyped right so
descartes gets read not as descartes
but as sort of a as i mentioned second
or third
hand uh you know intro to philosophy
presentation
of descartes and to me that's
problematic
because if we're going to say that
as ben irvine is the philosophers aren't
supplying us with the answers you would
actually have to go to the text and see
whether they did supply you with the
answers and if you're going to say that
they said this
you really have to make sure that they
actually did present things the way that
that you're saying they did
and in some cases they didn't in this
this work so that that's a problem
uh i'll give you a few examples of that
um so here we go
you know he says philosophers tend to
retreat from life many of them lack
normal social contact many live as
though in a dream a drift of reality
and then he says this derealization
takes these two forms and reality of
skepticism and idealism
and he um you know that's a very
sweeping statement
i i it doesn't correspond to my
experience of my peers as philosophers
it might
correspond to you know irvine's
experience but
i i don't know how you even like would
would
back up something like that and i think
that appeals to something in in some
readers
that is going to be detrimental to them
there will be oh yeah
yeah man i i know what that's like you
know and they're
using their own inadequate experience
depriving themselves of the experience
of
engaging with philosophers who don't fit
that bill
another example is on page 108
um here we go
um where he's talking about kant right
and he tells us that uh he's talking
about kant's numeral realm and says you
know
we can't know anything about it well
no kant says that we can't know
something about it in the groundwork for
the metaphysics of morals if you read to
the third part
right so you know we actually learn more
about it in moral
practical life than we do from a
theoretical perspective so there's you
know
there's kind of a misrepresentation of
kant going on here
um a little bit uh
later on um let me see no that's that's
probably enough examples
already um what else there's some
appeals to
eastern you know modes of thought
as opposed to western you know i
understand i'm not going to say that
that it's
you can't talk about the term eastern at
all but each of them is as
vast a cultural field and
and as varied as western philosophy is
so if we're talking about indian or
chinese philosophy you know
there's there's a vast thing there and
we don't want to generalize under the
rubric of
eastern there's some discussion of
hinduism there's some discussion of
buddhism
the buddhist discussion is almost
completely taken from one school of
buddhism which is an important school
but is not representative of buddhism as
a whole and that's zen
there's you know some references to alan
watts which i always find a little
suspicious they're kind of shortcuts uh
you know
what we want is if we're going to talk
about buddhism
or hinduism or taoism and
and you know taoism you know
the contemporary way of spelling is with
a d rather than a t
which makes you you know what's going on
here you know what texts are being
relied on here
you really want to go to the source text
and provide more
and you know respect the differentiation
within within the traditions
so that's that's something that i found
a little bit
off in it um i i'll also say that
um the the last second the last chapter
was deeply unsatisfying you know where
it's treating ethics
uh for example there's this uh reference
to
stoics and existentialists spelling you
know with a
lowercase s which okay
there is a difference between the two
but you know saying that
here's how we can like summarize their
their points of view in in two sentences
philosophers who are existentialists
encourage us to recognize our choices
and attitudes influence whether we
become happy or not
and philosophers who are stoics argue we
can only be truly happy when we've
mastered our feelings and emotions
that's only the tiniest bit of stoicism
and stoics also like existentialists
say that we have to recognize our
choices and attitudes influence whether
we become happy or not
as do you diamondus who he talks about
which would include presumably aristotle
so there's a lot of kind of sloppy one
sentence
summaries of entire vast schools of
philosophy
and why they don't have that much to
contribute by comparison to
ben irvine so that's you know
it's it's straw manning quite a lot
throughout the the entire thing
i think this is a problem uh later on
he's got this
this reference to post-modernists and it
does you know i
this is not something i can recognize as
a good description of it post-modernism
is a bizarre blend of moral determinism
moral perspectivism and idealism
according to the post-modernist
our morality is always the morality of
our society moral determinism
but we collectively choose this morality
moral perspectivism
just as we create our reality through
our shared beliefs idealism
no that's that's not postmodernism
that's that's jumping on the bandwagon
of criticizing postmodernism when you
really mean something like relativism
or consumerism or some other thing that
you don't like
and so you know it's not doing any any
work here other than like appealing to
people who
already uh buy into you know some
post-modernism is bad
uh sort of thing so that's a problem
there's there's i would say a rather
superficial treatment
of four different approaches in
in uh ethics you know typically i mean
it's nice that he brought in more than
just
utilitarianism deontology and virtue
ethics
but the depictions of them are sort of
like
you know these are the sort of things
that you see in in
forums where people have only read a bit
and they're not
real presentations of them and then he
talks about sentimentalism
and then kind of bizarrely endorses
g.e moore and his principia ethica
as like the way to go beyond these forms
it's you know it's it's kind of
refreshing to find people who think that
moore
is a great philosopher because
it's pretty rare and i'm and i'm saying
that not just to like appeal to
popularity or something
it's pretty rare because principia
ethica
you know it's an interesting book but
it's not a very good book of ethics
and that direction is you know
it's it's kind of hard to say anything
uh good about
it so you know there's some deeply
unsatisfying things in here there's a
lot of places where you're like yeah
that okay i can see how
you could go in that direction but i
don't know why you had to like
you know bash or downgrade or stereotype
all these other
people along the way just come straight
out and say what it is that that you
want right
and then it would have been a much much
stronger book
had it been much more positive in
incorporating more than just a few
endorsements of like you know say g more
right or
another favorite in here is is arthur
schopenhauer
so those are those are some some
problematic aspects i think
the other thing that i'll say is the
further reading very idiosyncratic
and not really that well connected to
what's in the book so it includes
um you know
dawkins god delusion and chalmers the
conscious mind okay those are those are
good the things
jules evans philosophy life for life and
other dangerous situations
um he includes his own book einstein and
the mindful cycling
stephen pinker you know uh the and then
the only
philosophers from past philosophy
as opposed to contemporary stuff that
he's actually
referencing here uh in a book where he's
he's brought up descartes and brought up
you know
all these other thinkers over the course
of it arsart and schopenhauer
and the sartre is a reference to nausea
which makes sense because he's talking
about the you know the chestnut tree
but he also brings up some stuff that
should be from you know existentialism
is a humanism
uh and that's just not there so the
further reading is not particularly
helpful i would say for somebody coming
to this book
for the first time um so those are quite
a few
uh things that i've registered there uh
but
you know i think we we have to be
brutally honest in a sadler's honest
review
all right my final thoughts on this book
i think that you know i'm going to give
it a qualified
endorsement if you if you want to read a
book that
you know does say some interesting
things about mindfulness and has some
uh decent exercises worked out in it
even if you disagree with the author on
some of the ways in which he's going and
some of the
let's call them frankly
misrepresentations of classic
all the way down to contemporary
philosophical uh
authors and positions if you if you get
past that
and you look at what's good in the book
i mean it might be a nice book for you
to have
it's not too pricey and it's quite
attractive
and it could be you know a good book for
like you know provoking
thoughts on your part it could also be a
decent gift to give people
it's definitely not the sort of book
that you want to take
as articulating the last word
or even you know a a
one of the last words in a selection
on the topics that it's discussing um
but it you know it could be it could be
a nice book for somebody to receive as a
gift
or to lend somebody which is probably
what i'm going to do with it myself
um and you know it it it could lead to
actually saying okay he says this about
deckard let me let me read descartes and
see what descartes actually says or hume
actually says or
kant actually says right that would be
quite quite good
um so you know qualified endorsement of
it there's there's some good points
there's some bad
points and that's what i have to say
you